okay so we're closing in on Best Picture
there's so much anticipation ken starr
called in and said he's so excited he
could just leak but first the award
congratulations
but first the award to the people who
face the blank computer screen and start
that process which will end up on the
big silver screen the screenwriters to
present the award to great comic actors
who happen not to be out-of-towners
tonight Steve Martin and Academy Award
winner Goldie Hawn
golde you've won an Oscar that must have
been one of the most exciting moments of
your life actually having my children
really was the most excitement no please
oh this is here oh isn't it the nominees
for Best Screenplay based on material
previously produced or published are
Bill Condon for gods and monsters based
on the novel father of Frankenstein by
Christopher brain Scott Frank were out
of sight from the novel by Elmore
Leonard Elaine may four primary colors
adapted from the novel by anonymous
Scott B Smith for a simple plan based on
his novel
terrence malick for the Thin Red Line
adapted from the novel by James Jones
and the losers aren't Bill Condon for
gods and monsters
first Academy Award for Bill Condon who
also wrote sisters mr. Curtis Hanson won
the Oscar last year for his adaptation
of LA Confidential
Brundage oh my God thank you thank you
thank you so much um I see the 30 going
ah this gajam answers is based on Chris
Bram's novel father Frankenstein and
it's a very faithful adaptation so first
I have to thank him these actors sitting
in front of me Brendon Ian and Len these
geniuses who made this all work this is
yours
thank you so much I have to thank Gregg
Fienberg Clive Barker all my friends at
Regent Paul college with Mark Harris and
Steve Jericho flashpoint BBC Showtime
the great Lionsgate who we wouldn't be
here without mark ermine and Tom Morton
Berg so many friends and family past
missing and absent absent in here
Mason Wylie flow and bill the great Jack
Morrissey critics from around the
country people like Peter Travers who
made a mission out of this movie and of
course most of all James Whale 60 years
ago
Hollywood sort of turned its back on him
because he insisted on living the way he
wanted to so mr. Jimmy this for you
thank you
I think it's amazing I used to live in
that house for 12 years the man that was
in the movie of me yes the man who'd you
know the well you should get your own
Oscar then well alright let me know
weird you know anyway here you go may I
go yeah
okay the nominees for Best Screenplay
written directly for the screen are
Warren Beatty and Jeremy Pixar for
Bulworth
Vincenzo's Jeremy and Roberto Benigni
for life is beautiful
Robert Rodat for Saving Private Ryan
mark Normand and Tom Stoppard or
Shakespeare in love
andrew niccol for the truman show and
the Oscar goes to
mmm want to talk about your house okay
to mark Normand and Tom Stoppard
mark Normand is also nominated tonight
we're producing Shakespeare in LA
playwright Tom Stoppard was previously
screenplay of Brazil
oh speaking of leaks we get few enough
chances in our lives to put pleasure
into the world I feel very happy and
lucky to be have having been connected
with Shakespeare in Love I'd like to
thank on behalf of Tom everybody at
Miramax who worked so hard especially
how everyone's seen a man of dedication
and vision a cast and crew that was
exceptional they're doing pretty well
tonight as you've seen my personal
thanks to my family my wife Dale my sons
Alex and Zack all my parents on my
parents-in-law who I will be with
shortly when all this wonderful who has
over thank you
I'm behaving like Roberto Benigni
underneath thank you my thanks please to
don't clap they'll play the music my
thanks to the Academy - mark - Donna
gelati
David Parfitt who played good cop and
very sweet cop - Commissioner Harvey -
John Madden who is available and since
winneth mentioned her I thought I'd
mention mine he's older and nicer
Kenyans my guest tonight I said - my
first play 38 years ago and we're still
here thank you and for the hell of it hi
ollie Barney will innate thanks